[Music]
hi everyone i'm jeev nahegde and i'm
julian teo and we're both customer
engineers at google cloud and we're
excited to share with you all about this
new series of videos that we are
launching specially catered to help
startups
our mission begins with you and we're
highly invested in helping you to build
your business with the innovative
technology and holistic support from
google cloud b whether you're in the
early days of product market fit or
you've just received your next round of
funding we are here to help you grow
keeping our focus on startups we are
creating a series of videos for
technical enablement to build a
sustainable and successful business over
the long term and solve your toughest
challenges with google's proven
technology and multifaceted partnership
introducing technical guides for
startups
this series is especially designed to
help startups and beginners and to also
at the same time understand how other
startups are leveraging our products and
solutions this series is especially
catered to match your startup's stage of
growth as well as product and program
engagement
we will have multiple video savings
focusing on different stages for every
step of your startup journey all the way
from start where we will work on helping
beginners at early stage startups which
are in their pre-trial phase to build
deploy and manage new applications on
google cloud from start to finish
this can be for everyone just starting
out and validating their minimum viable
product
and moving on to build this is where
we'll be working with startups that have
already launched on google cloud to
scale and optimize their existing
deployments in order to reach their
target audience
and finally grow
where we help startups that are looking
to grow and achieve planet skill
deployments on google cloud
so this can be leveraged for scale ups
growing to meet the needs of new
customers and markets
and in this series which is the start
series as you probably guessed by now is
to help early stage startups to get
started on google cloud through this
series we'll be navigating together
through a series of topics on google
cloud and to kick off as you can see
this is our launch video to show you and
let you know what you can expect in the
following videos to come
in our next video we will be sharing on
how you can get started on google cloud
and also go over the google cloud
console
following that we'll be looking into
application deployment
as well as the google kubernetes engine
following that we shall do a fresh
deployment where we will show you how
you can build on google compute engine
and further manage networking
configurations
and explore the database configurations
for the same application just so you
know how the entire flow for a single
application works once we're done with
that we'll then take a look into how
firebase can help you to build improve
and grow your applications and then from
there we'll then navigate through the
landscape of ci cd deployments with
google cloud
we will also go over logging monitoring
and more for your deployed application
using cloud operations
and finally look into billing and cost
optimization as well as learn about the
support packages and that'll be the
wrap-up of start series and from there
we will move on to build and grow
and so for our very next stop in our
second video getting started on google
cloud we will be showing you how you can
get started by first creating an account
an organization
and project
we will also run through the google
cloud console platform
and cover how you can build your
security foundation on google cloud with
identity and access management for your
resources
so stay tuned as we begin this journey
and we'll be working alongside you to
explore concepts step-by-step guides and
use cases across industries
and that is a wrap
please do subscribe to this youtube
channel to stay up to date and don't
forget to click on the bell icon to
receive notifications each time we post
a new video in this series we hope that
you are as excited as we are to embark
on this journey together
and so
hang tight and we'll see you on the
other side
[Music]
you